as detail-oriented as Game of Thrones
usually is the fantasy drama has
featured not one but two immersion
breaking mistakes during its final
season on television after spotting a
stray copy cup that was accidentally
left in a shot on the fourth episode of
Thrones Season eight viewers noticed yet
another erroneous object in frame on the
series finale weirdly enough this
embarrassing gap is also beverage based
making it seem like the crew on the
final season of the show may have had a
bit of a drinking problem spoilers ahead
following Daenerys Targaryen fire and
fury siege of King's Landing that killed
thousands of innocent people
Tyrion Lannister resigned as her hand
and asked Jon Snow to find the strength
to make a difficult decision that would
ensure the safety of the Seven Kingdoms
kill Danny so she doesn't harm anyone
else under the guise of liberation fast
forward a few weeks and Tyrion emerges
for his trial which turns into a meeting
of the minds with members of the
remaining great houses of Westeros who
decide that they will now and
forevermore choose the king or queen
just as Tyrion is walking up to everyone
the camera flips perspective to show
Samwell Tarly Edmure Tully and an
unknown character watching the last
Lannister sibling approaching keep your
eyes on Sam during this moment and
you'll see a plastic water bottle near
his foot it's about half hidden behind
his boot but it's definitely noticeable
looks like actor John Bradley was
getting parched during Tyrians big
speech which is understandable listening
to talkers makes me thirsty later on in
the scene a second water bottle can be
spotted behind sir Davos Seaworth must
have been a hot day in the dragon pit
plastic water bottles are obviously very
out of place in Westeros in your life a
wine water and the first of the two
errors stuck out two tons of Watchers at
home just as viewers were split over
season 8 as a whole they were also
divided over water bottle gate one fan
wrote seven hells they did it again it's
a plastic water bottle another was
frustrated to the point of all caps
tweeting after spotting the plastic
water bottle in frame writing
please there was a plastic water bottle
in this episode not again
voice actor Troy Hughes was equally as
upset finding it hard to believe that
the game of thrones crew could allow
oversights like these in the finale
he wrote seriously it's the finale of
Game of Thrones everybody is watching
and you leave a water bottle on the set
CBS sports writer wil Brinson felt that
the bottle blunder was a microcosm of
the last two seasons of Thrones he
tweeted Game of Thrones leaving a
plastic water bottle sitting there in
the finale is such a perfect symbolism
for a show that spent the last two
seasons rushing to get done and ignoring
the important little details that made
it great in the first place conversely
plenty of others thought that the
mistake was ultimately harmless one
viewer tweeted first a Starbucks coffee
cup and now a water bottle I love it
it's super silly another joke that HBO
must have secured a couple of
sponsorships for the final season of
Game of Thrones let's all clap for the
sponsors of this season the plastic
water bottle and the Starbucks cup
someone else even defended the Game of
Thrones team noting that framing isn't
easy and the crew might have been paying
closer attention to the actors
performances the lighting and the
costumes than whether there were any
water bottles visible in the shot for
some fans everything that was supposed
to be included in the game of Thrones
finale is more than enough to make them
forget about the out of place beverage
for others the water bottle mishap
serves as another nail in the coffin of
a season they weren't all that satisfied
with like Tyrion said during his rousing
finale monologue there's nothing more
powerful in the world than a good story
but there's nothing that can carnage
tale like Game of Thrones as easily as
an absent-minded slip-up check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you